Let's move on to another type of depressant. That's opioids. Opioids are
medically very useful, because, they're effective pain relievers. Opiates
include morphine, heroin, as well as oxycodone, among other drugs. The main
ingredient of these painkillers comes from the opium poppy. Although, some of
the drugs use a synthetic version. Acute effects of opiates are pain relief,
confusion, lower blood pressure, decreased respiration, euphoria or a dreamlike
state as well as decreased coordination. In addition, they can produce nausea
and vomiting as well as. Constipation just as have seen with other drugs.
Opioids can be very helpful when properly used as medical treatment, for
example, receiving morphine after having a surgery. However, these are often
abused. As with other central nervous system depressant, we see people display
tolerance to the effects of these drugs. Meaning, the person will have to take
more of the drug to produce the original effect. Now let's go back to Susan to
talk a little bit about heroin, a commonly abused opioid.